Man, I feel like crap.
I just came from
a trashy Indian restaurant
in a strip mall.
Not bad food, though.
Got pretty lucky.
Got the hottest,
baddest curry
I ever ate in my life.
Place called Naan Sense,
Indian joint,
just, like, Terminal 3.
It's like, I'm going
to my brother's wedding
on Sunday, and it's like,
I don't even want to go.
I don't even like my brother.
My brother's, like, a jerk.
Don't like his wife.
She's, like, a bitch.
[rumbling]
I stayed with them
for, like, three weeks.
She was a bitch
to me, man.
I put my feet
on her coffee table.
She was like, "Don't get
your feet on my coffee--"
I'm like, "Who are you?"
[demonic growling]
[rumbling]
Scrimps.
A ginger broad, man, like...
[rumbling]
Scrimps.
Those are the worst people
on the planet.
So I said that to him.
I said that to him
in the parking lot.
I cornered him
a little bit, sure.
(demonic voice)
Scrimps.
He swung on me.
Can you believe that?
It's like, who sings
on their own brother, man?
Yeah, I swung back...
[demonic growling]
But that's cool, you know.
It's like, I haven't
seen him for a while,
but now I got this expensive
wedding I have to go to.
So it's crazy.
I got to get my tickets,
and that's a whole situation.
I hate doing that.
And--hold on a second.
Hey, hey, pal pal.
Start on
the downstairs bits.
I'm in the middle
of a conversation up here.
[rumbling]
- Hey.
- Of course, of course.
Whatever you say.
Thank you.
Sorry about that.
Just have
a little guy here
working on my suit...
(demonic voice)
From the eternal, from within.
You know, I mean, there's always
chicks at the wedding, right?
There is a guy in there.
- The answer is yes.
- [muttering nervously]
And hopefully, you know,
I can get, like,
two down in one evening,
you know?
[exhales]
And speaking of
"two down in one evening,"
if they've got popcorn shrimp
and little lobster rolls,
I'm a happy man.
But they're not
going to have that...
(demonic voice)
Stop!
Who goes there?
Sal.
My name is Sal.
(demonic voice)
Sal...the end is near.
What?
Why--what--
[stammering]
What do you mean?
(demonic voice)
Everything is changing.
What do you mean?
(demonic voice)
The end is near, Sal.
No, I don't know
what you mean.
What do you mean?
I don't want to die!
(demonic voice)
There's nothing you can do.
The end is near.
Everything is changing.
From the eternal,
from within.
No, I don't want to die!
What do you mean?
(demonic voice)
The end is near.
(Sal)
What?
[squeaky fart]
Sorry about that, man.
Of course.
[bell chimes]
Change is coming.